good morning Hank it's Tuesday so when I
was a kid there was a popular joke
construction called the Russian reversal
the first time I heard a Russian
reversal was in a miller lite commercial
in 1985 where the comedian Yakov
Smirnoff said in America you can always
find a party in Soviet Russia party
always finds you but the joke is
actually much older than that it was
used in a 1938 Cole Porter musical and
in a 1960s episode of the show laugh-in
where the joke was in America everybody
watches television in the old country
television watches you ha that's funny
everyone said before our television
started gathering reams of information
about our viewing habits be careful who
you laugh at friends for in time you may
become them but right Russian reversal
jokes were basically low-level
xenophobic weapons of the Cold War
trying to get Americans to believe that
their country where you could always
find a party and watch television was
perfect in purported contrast to life in
the Soviet Union there were of course
also American reversal jokes my favorite
being in the Soviet Union people
sometimes rob banks in capitalist
America bank robs you and there were
jokes that refuted both ideologies like
this one from Moldova an American
educator Emil Robbie under capitalism
man exploits man under communism it's
the other way around of course these
days the Russian reversal has been memed
to near-extinction like so much else on
the internet but I still find the joke
construction really really interesting
because it starts out with you having
agency over something and then ends up
with that something having agency over
you like in a way Michael Pollan's
famous observation about corn is a
Russian reversal joke he pointed out
that while it's true that corn has
adapted to our human interests if you
look at it from corns perspective we
have adapted a lot to corns interests
like we've changed our habitats and our
diets and our travel patterns to make
corn more plentiful and when you look at
it that way corn kind of becomes the
farmer and we kind of become the crop
and when you start looking for these
jokes you see them everywhere like for
starters in Shakespeare in Richard ii
the king says i wasted time and now time
doth waste me there's a Winnie the Pooh
story where piglet says he's so small
that he doesn't fly a kite so much as
the kite flies him and in the
oscar-nominated feature film boss baby
the titular character says either you
run the day or the day runs you slightly
off-topic but the book
that movie is adapted from is excellent
anyway I used this construction a lot in
my book Turtles all the way down you're
the storyteller but you're also the
story told you think you're spending
money but the money spending you it's
cetera because the book is about what
happens when you feel like you're not
captaining the ship of your so-called
self and I think what I love most about
Russian reversals is that they can
reveal how weak we are before the forces
of time and the wind and money and
everything else and in general I find it
helpful to take a kind of Russian
reversal style look at any big force in
our lives like take the social internets
algorithms for instance are they
informing us or are we informing them or
free markets do markets exist to make
human lives better and more efficient or
do human lives exist to make markets
better and more efficient of course the
Russian reversal can create a false
dichotomy you can waste time and be
wasted by time and as we all know now
you can watch television and be watched
by your television and maybe there's no
tension at all in some reversals like I
guess it's possible that whatever makes
markets more efficient is good for human
lives and whatever is good for human
lives makes markets more efficient but
in my experience anyway that kind of
ideological rigidity rarely holds up to
careful scrutiny and I like the Russian
reversal because it asks us to consider
where the power is really centered in
our discourse sometimes the answer is
obvious the humans who plant the corn
have much more power than the corn that
gets planted but sometimes it isn't is
the real power with the Twitter user who
chooses what they tweet and who they
follow or with the algorithm that
decides which tweets the user actually
sees and is the real power with the
people who make markets work or with the
markets that make people work I don't
think those questions have easy answers
but I do think that looking at them
backwards has a way of telling us truths
we otherwise might miss Hank I'll see
you on Friday